[Music]
selective education news submitted by
blacks on black sauce Florida residents
can now challenge to remove science
curriculum taught in public schools what
what are they gonna do now resolution so
I mean if they're gonna remove science
then what are they going to teach like
[ __ ] flat earthing nah no dude that
shit's real right this is weird
you know I'd be ok if they remove
science with I don't know like real life
skills I guess if they don't want to
actually you know what signs kind
important though it seems you like a lot
of logic a lot of logic you just do
about the world in a very objective in a
physical sense I am talking about
removing the whole subject there's a
play about like residents and even if
they don't have kids in these public
schools just by living in these certain
counties they'll be able to have the
power to send complaints about any sort
of curriculum that they oppose for
example the evolution thing so pretty
much whatever the child is having
trouble with you can tell the school he
ain't going there net or you could force
your belief systems on others that's
just important in the chemistry biology
physics yeah so recently there is
legislation that just about went into
effect this is the fact that requires
school boards to hire an unbiased
hearing officer who will then handle all
the complaints that they will receive
about any particulars like curriculum
that these schools are presenting for
these students that such as
instructional materials or text books or
movies or novels or anything that's
being used in schools that certain
residents might be opposed to they can
take it up with this unbiased hearing
officer and then that person will then
determine if they should remove it I
think this is the worst thing suggestion
box and like letting people complain
nowadays is like the worst thing because
everyone's going to complain about some
stupid ass [ __ ] this novel has something
about bullying I don't want you to
[ __ ] read it to my kids what to do
with the voice of the smoker lady I
don't know I don't agree with this
science [ __ ]
I figured I like it what would be
grounds for removal is if they believe
that the content or the material is
pornographic or that is not suited for
the students needs so right now there's
porn that's being taught at schools
because what [ __ ] school is
reflective again they're like just in
case we forgot to [ __ ] filter through
all the porn please parents let us know
that's what it sounds like it is because
all the atoms are naked and they don't
have clothes on mmm they're always naked
Adams in the chemistry books oh and I
might be gay because there's just
nothing but atoms are attracted to each
other yeah that homosexual [ __ ]
covalent bond oh [ __ ] I'm so gay yeah
and they're saying that or if the
material is not appropriate for that
specific age group or grade level so
yeah that this thing is pretty crazy
because then there's supporters for this
bill that are saying like yeah you know
we're going to go after evolution we're
going to go after crow address their
climate change there's like one
particular supporter said that evolution
and global warming are being taught as a
reality it is all you want to just
fantasy know that they then one parents
point was saying like well then there
are two theories on how humanity was
created one is the creationism the other
one no that is not even a theory that's
fantasy
well this mother is claiming that it's a
theory and then so she's saying well why
is my daughter only learning the other
one the evolution theory then you could
go to their home they don't teach Harry
Potter as [ __ ] reality these parents
want their kids to a rapid drop yeah I
mean this is so skip it the science is
important and you know here's the thing
too like especially from like a
religious aspect you're not supposed to
like shield people from different types
of thought if you are strong in your
faith then you keep strong in your faith
while knowing other things and you also
explore other things to kind of bolster
how you originally believed it doesn't
help your religion just by ignoring
everything else it just keeps you
ignorant but that's like the intelligent
Christian right we're talking to that
attacked our banjo
now Jesus rubber nutsack [ __ ] never
know [ __ ] I feel like that's what it
sounds like to be if it is not Jesus
then it's the devil yeah the Bible Belt
that's the ones that dance with snakes
and [ __ ] the rattlesnakes if it doesn't
bite me then Jesus loves me you know
like it's funny because like like
science - I hated science growing up
like I [ __ ] hated that [ __ ] I thought
it was boring all that more where's man
partially because of like the teachers
that I had I don't think they trying to
make it exciting on a teaching of
exactly and also but at the same time
now as an adult I can understand how
important science is because it helped
me understand what's going on around me
yeah this table isn't just a table I
understand my wife's here why my head's
not going through it it helps you kind
of wrap your head around reality you
know so even though you can't apply it
to your job it actually helps just with
as a human being to understand things
very well the [ __ ] scientific method
- it makes sense yeah you know I don't
know I feel like when you live in a
place like this the only thing you could
really do is because the whole community
is like this people all agreeing on this
statute or whatever this is just move
out how to find another place where to
put your kids in because if the whole
county is like a bunch of [ __ ]
rejects and their stupid [ __ ] then guess
what's going to happen they're all going
to go to the school would be like nah
and it's not going to you know their
kids aren't going to have a chance to
grow and go like actually everyone in my
town and everyone is [ __ ] dumb and
then they could like upgrade themselves
but they're not going to be able to do
that anymore because they don't have the
option to you know what I want people to
do I want scientists to [ __ ] recreate
the wooly mammoth
I want to see how big that [ __ ]
is where did this come from you know I
will tell my science Oh Jurassic Park
man no but they have the they founder
than a fully frozen [ __ ] woolly
mammoth with the ball sack and
everything so while they [ __ ] plat
fashion elefante so they were talking
about it years ago I think I read this
article like maybe like eight years ago
maybe even further back so I assume that
they would have already replicated one
by now but they haven't done it so I'm
just waiting not telling us
busta elephant vagina open is that day
under like the woolly mammoth it's like
pulling substantially bigger than an
elephant right yeah I don't know I don't
know because thing about making a hybrid
I forgot to measure the last time I saw
one they're all extinct because we ate
them to death if the humans fault
Oh woolly mammoth no should I know that
it's the humans the dodo birds gone too
just recently there's this group in
Florida called Florida citizens for
science and they're just urging people
in all these communities to like really
be involved especially if you have kids
in these school systems to really look
out for all this like curriculum changes
in voicing your own opinions and whether
you disagree with it or not because
they're saying like you know if you're
not there and willing to stand up for
sound science education then we're gonna
I don't understand why people today are
against science things like Trump is
leading it down he's the one that's
saying like math sciences like climate
Rome whatever he gets a [ __ ] disease
I don't want him to take any [ __ ]
medication then there's so many things
that people use not it is attributed to
science and if you think is that [ __ ]
useless don't use any of it then you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I don't know
Campos anti science that's crazy
he though on stopping the whole climate
you know that's a Republican the
Republicans won't accept that it's
there's no climate change know that but
that's that's because it has a lot to do
with big oil oil stuff like that and
they get a lot of money from them so
they personally might believe that it's
happening but they're getting paid for
they won't say anything
that's Republicans necessarily chump too
many for what I see he's like the
loudest voice out there saying climate
change of philosophy moral endures I'd
like these science people they should
just form their own School District
happens all the time we're like a bunch
of parents or faculty don't agree with
existing with the existing policy and
they just form their own stuff that's
why I think schools should be like
privatize because you know there's
there's already Christian schools yes so
no that's right it's also like yeah if
you want to you know go up in a
Christian environment and learn the
Bible as you learn whatever go to the
Christian school
but if you want sky in then you go to
the sky in schools and in public schools
they have shitty lunches anyway so let's
do away with them where the poor kids
going to go I don't know yeah you're
monitoring that there's a bunch of dope
public schools do you know just last
time when the dude just was here and is
telling about all the dope public
schools I started looking them up
there's a lot of like highly highly
rated public schools that are rated way
above private schools so I think it's
like the parents do their research and
they can put their kids and you can also
go check out the school check out the
curriculum and then you can see what you
want your kids to learn there's a South
Pasadena high school that everybody
everybody wants their kids to go to it's
one of the highest-rated around here but
their kids are [ __ ] dumbass but I mean
socially dumb I [ __ ] wanna count the
[ __ ] out of those [ __ ] little ideas
just one kid though
oh there's one kid that came out of that
I [ __ ] hate it
boy little [ __ ] rich kids man [ __ ]
them dude a South Pasadena rich kids
it's not like San Marino can I see such
a mental balance I was looking at their
curriculum like they they're heavy in
arts there's acting theater department
they're like all kinds of I can get the
paintbrush and stick it up their [ __ ]
ah what I hate them just because they're
rich and I didn't go over that way
[ __ ] that dude I want to drive the
Beverly Hills and [ __ ] punch somebody
in the face you're [ __ ] rich your
parents don't love you and give you
attention but they give you money you're
like I want that yeah what's that like
what's that like I get the opposite my
parents care for me they take me to the
parking button we go to the beach
together and they okay buddy what if it
feel like I want to be a neglected rich
kid that gets a lot of money I mean
they're kids like that online school too
but they are mainly the fast I had not a
fairly conventional Michael everybody
was broken [ __ ] in my school like I
think like the kid that had an emotion
was the one that was working the most
jobs so he was the one that had money
but other than that mostly everybody in
my school was relatively not that well
off my friend uh Francis him and his
little brother they're like refugees
they're not refugees actually they're
just parachute kids they're really rich
yeah their parents just left them here
to do all their schooling since like
junior high elementary school and then
he told me that his little brother would
cry almost every night
because he misses his mom because
playing Super Nintendo because he was
here in like six or seventh grade but
his little brother was in elementary
school and then I was like your life
sucks but at the same time you [ __ ]
live alone or like you live it you have
your own room with the whole like you
know how they yeah yeah and then pretty
much you get like people to cook for you
you get all the [ __ ] new video games
you get like everything [ __ ] so much
you get all this [ __ ] that's what I want
money can't buy you love or hugs
we were poor and I still didn't have
love oh you're just a fun bunch of got
[ __ ] both ways here to get money or
million [ __ ] this mom was right there
but he didn't getting out of that that's
got my ass beat I found loving
gangbanging what's up you sexy [ __ ]
useless [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
want to follow us you could check out
all our [ __ ] link to the description
box below you [ __ ] [ __ ] then that
videos are up there
[Music]